الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيم اعتدلوا
واستو سووا الصف سدوا الخلل ريتن
لاينز الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تلك الرسل فضلنا بعضهم على بعض منهم
من كلم الله ورفع بعضهم
درجات واتينا عيسى ابن مريم البينات
وايدناه بروح
القدس ولو شاء الله ما اقتتل الذين من
بعدهم من بعد ما
جاءتهم
البينات ولكن اختلفوا فمنهم من امن ومنهم
من
كفر ولو شاء الله اتلوا ولكن الله يفعل ما
يريد يا ايها الذين امنوا
انفقوا من قبل
مما
رزقناكم من قبل ان ياتي يوم لا بيع فيه
ولا خله ولا
شفاعه
والكافرون هم الظالمون
الله لا اله الا هو الحي
القيوم لا تاخذه سنه ولا نوم له ما في
السماوات وما في الارض من ذا الذي يشفع
عنده الا
باذنه يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم
ولا يحيطون بشيء من علمه الا بما
شاء وسع كرسيه السماوات
والارض ولا يؤوده
حفظهما وهو العلي العظيم
[Silence]
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لا اكراه في الدين قد تبين الرشد من
الغي فمن يكفر بالطاغوت
ويؤمن بالله فقد استمسك بالعروه الوثقى لا
انفصام لها والله سميع
عليم الله ولي الذين امنوا يخرجهم من من
الظلمات الى
النور الله ولي الذين امنوا يخرجهم من
النور والذين كفروا
اولياؤهم الطاغوت
يخرجونهم من النور الى
الظلمات
اولئك اصحاب
النار هم فيها
خالدون الم تر الى الذي
ج ابراهيم في
ربه ان اتاه الله الملك اذ قال ابراهيم
ربي الذي يحيي
ويميت قال انا احيي
واميت قال ابراهيم
فان الله ياتي بالشمس من المشرق
فات بها من المغرب فبهت الذي كفر والله لا
يهدي القوم
الظالمين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكب الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكب الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
ا
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ا ادنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين او كالذي مر على قريه وهي خاويه على
عروشها قال
انا يحيي هذه الله بعد
موتها فاماته الله 100 عام ثم بعثه قال كم
لبثت قال لبثت يوما او بعض يوم قال بل
لبثت 100 عام فانظر الى طعامك وش رابك لم
يتسنه وانظر الى حمارك ولنجعلك ايه للناس
وانظر الى
العظام وانظر الى العظام كيف ننشزها
ثم نكسوها
لحما فلما تبين له قال اعلم ان الله على
كل كل شيء
قدير واذ قال ابراهيم رب ارني كيف تحيي
الموتى قال اولم تؤمن قال بلى ولكن
ليطمئن
قلبي قال فخذ اربعه من الطير فصرهن
اليك ثم اجعل على كل جبل من هن جزءا ثم
ادعهن ياتينك
سعيا واعلم
ان الله عزيز
حكيم مثل الذين ينفقون اموالهم في سبيل
الله كمثل
حبه كمثل حبه انبتت سبع
سنابل في كل سم بله 100 حبه والله يضاعف
لمن
يشاء والله واسع
عليم الذين ينفقون اموالهم في سبيل الله
ثم لا
يتبعون ثم لا يتبعون ما انفقوا
من ولا
اذى لهم اجرهم عند ربهم ولا خوف عليهم ولا
هم
يحزنون قول معروف ومغفره خير من صدقه
يتبعها
اذى والله غني حليم يا ايها الذين امنوا
لا تبطلوا صد
قكم بالمن والاذى كالذي
ينفق كالذي ينفق ماله
رئاء الناس ولا يؤمن بالله واليوم
الاخر فمثله كمثل صفوان عليه تراب فاصابه
وابل فتركه صلدا
لا يقدرون على
شيء
مما
كسبوا والله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومثل الذين ينفقون اموالهم ابتغاء
مرضاه الله
وتثبيتا من انفسهم كمثل
جنه كمثل جنه بربوه اصاب ها وابل فاتت
اكلها
ضعفين وان لم يصبها وابل
فطل فان لم يصبها وابل فطل والله بما
تعملون
بصير ايود احدكم ان تكون له جنه من نخيل
واعناب تجري من تحتها الانهار له فيها من
كل الثمرات
له فيها من كل الثمرات
واصابه الكبر وله
ذريه
ضعفاء فاصابها
اعصار فاصابها
اعصار فيه نار
فاحترقت كذلك يبين الله لكم الايات لعلكم
تتفكرون يا ايها الذين امنوا انفقوا من
طيبات ما كسبتم ومما اخرجنا لكم ومما
اخرجنا لكم من الارض ولا تيمم الخبيث منه
تنفقون تنفق ولستم باخذيه الا ان تغمضوا
فيه واعلموا
ان الله غف واعلموا ان الله غني
حميد الشيطان يعدكم الفقر
ويامركم بالفحشاء
والله يعدكم
مغفره منه وفضلا
والله واسع عليم يؤتي الحكمه من
يشاء ومن يؤتى الحكمه فقد اوتي خيرا
كثيرا وما يذكر الا اولو
الالباب وما
انفقتم من نفقه او نذرتم من نذر فان الله
الله
يعلمه فان الله يعلمه وما للظالمين من
انصار ان تبدوا الصدقات فنعم ما هي وان
تخفوها وتؤتوها
الفقراء فهو خير
لكم ويكفر
عنكم من سيئاتك
والله بما تعملون
خبير الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم الس عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين ليس عليك هداهم ولكن الله يهدي من
يشاء وما تنفقوا من خير
فلانفسكم وما تنفقوا الا ابتغاء وجه
الله وما تنفقوا من خير يوث اليكم وانتم
لا
تظلمون
للفقراء الذين احصروا في سبيل الله لا
يستطيعون ضربا في الارض لا يستطيعون ضربا
في الارض يحسبهم الجاهل
اغنياء يحسبهم الجاهل
اغنياء من التعفف من
التعفف تعرفهم بسيماهم لا يسالون الناس
الحافا وما
تنفقوا من خير
فان الله به
عليم ومثل الذين ينفقون
اموالهم بالليل والنهار سرا
وعلانيه فلهم اجرهم عند ربهم ولا خوف
عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون الذين ياكلون الربا لا يقومون الا
كما يقوم الذي يتخبطه الشيطان من المس ذلك
بانهم
قالوا انما البيع مثل الربا واحل الله
البيع وحرم
الربا فمن
جاءه موعظه من ربه
فانتهى فله ما سلف وامره الى الله ومن عاد
فاولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها خالدون
يمحق الله الربا ويربي
الصدقات والله لا يحب كل كفار
اثيم ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
واقاموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه لهم اجرهم عند ربهم ولا خوف عليهم
ولا هم يحزنون
يا ايها الذين امنوا ذروا ما بقي من
الربا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وذروا ما بقي من الربا ان
كنتم
مؤمنين فان لم تفعلوا فاذنوا بحرب من الله
ورسوله وان تبتم فلكم رؤوس
اموالكم لا تظلمون ولا
تظلمون وان كان ذو
عسره فنظره الى
ميسره وان تصدقوا خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون واتقوا يوما ترجعون فيه الى
الله ثم توف
كل نفس ما
كسبت ثم توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا
يظلمون يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا
تداينتم بدين الى اجل مسمى
فاكتبوه فاكتبوه وليكتب بينكم كاتب بالعدل
ولا يابك كاتب ان يكتب كما علمه الله
فليكتب ويمل للذي عليه الحق وليتق الله
ربه وليتق الله ربه ولا يبخس منه شيئا فان
كان الذي عليه الحق سفيها او ضعيفا او لا
يستطيع ان يمله فليملل وليه
بالعدل واستشهدوا رج واستشهدوا شهيدين من
رجالكم فان لم يكونا رجلين فرجل وامراتان
ممن ترضون من
الشهداء ان تضل احداهما فتذكر احداهما
الاخرى ولا يابى الشهداء
اذا ما
دعوا ولا تساموا ان تكتبوه صغيرا او كبيرا
الى اجله ذلكم اقسط عند الله واقوم
للشهاده وادنى الا
ترتابوا الا ان تكون تجاره حاضره تديرونها
بينكم فليس عليكم جناح
فليس عليكم جناح الا
تكتبوها واشهدوا اذا تبايعتم
ولا
يضار
كاتب ولا
شهيد وان تفعلوا
فانه فسوق بكم ويعلمك واتقوا الله
واتقوا الله
ويعلمكم الله والله بكل شيء عليم وان كنتم
على سفر ولم تجدوا كاتبا
فرهان
مقبوضه فان امن بعضكم بعضا فليؤد الذي
ائتمن
امانته فليؤد الذي ائتمن امانته
يتق الله ربه ولا تكتم
الشهاده ومن يكتمها
فانه اثم
قلبه والله بما
تعملون
عليم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضين
امين لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض وان
تبدوا ما في انفسكم او تخفوه
يحاسبكم به الله فيغفر لمن
يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء والله على كل شيء
قدير امن الرسول بما انزل اليه من ربه
والمؤمنون كل امن بالله
وملائكته وكتبه
ورسله لا نفرق بين احد من رسله وقالوا
سمعنا واطعنا غفرانك ربنا واليك
المصير لا يكلف الله نفسا الا
وسعها لها ما كسبت وعليها ما
اكتسبت ربنا لا تؤاخذنا ان نسينا او
اخطانا ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما
حملته على الذين من
قبلنا ربنا ولا
تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به واعف عنا واغفر
لنا
وارحمنا انت مولانا
فانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
م الله لا اله الا هو الحي
القيوم نزل عليك الكتاب بالحق مصدقا لما
بين يديه وانزل التوراه
والانجيل من قبل هدى الناس وانزل
الفرقان ان الذين يكفرون بايات الله لهم
عذاب
شديد ان الذين كفروا بايات الله لهم عذاب
شديد والله عزيز ذو
انتقام ان الله لا يخفى عليه شيء في الارض
ولا في
السماء هو الذي يصوركم في الارحام كيف
يشاء لا اله الا هو العزيز
الحكيم هو الذي انزل عليك الكتاب منه ايات
محكمات هن ام
الكتاب هن ام الكتاب واخر
متشابهات فاما الذين في قلوبهم زيغ
فيتبعون ما تشابه
منه فيتبعون ما تشابه منه
ابتغاء الفتنه
وابتغاء تاويله وما يعلم تاويله الا الله
والراسخون
في العلم يقولون امنا به كل من عند ربنا
وما يذكر الا اولو
الالباب ربنا لا تزق قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا
وهب لنا من لدنك
رحمه انك انت
الوهاب ربنا
انك جامع الناس ليوم لا ريب فيه ان الله
لا يخلف
الميعاد ان الذين كفروا لن تغني عنهم
اموالهم ولا اولادهم من الله شيئا
واولئك هم وقود النار كداب ال فرعون
والذين من قبلهم كذبوا بايات
الله كذبوا باياتنا فاخذهم الله
بذنوبهم ان الله شديد
العقاب والله شديد
العقاب قل للذين كفروا ستغلبون وتحشرون
الى جهنم وبئس المهاد قد كان لكم ايه في
فئتين
التقتا فئه تقاتل في سبيل الله واخرى
كافره يرونهم مثليهم راي العين والله يؤيد
بنصره من
يشاء ان في ذلك لعبره لاولي
الابصار ز للناس حب الشهوات من
النساء والبنين
والقناطير
المقنطره
والقناطير المقنطره من الذهب والفضه
والخيل المسومه والانعام
والحرث ذلك متاع الحياه
الدنيا والله عنده
حسنب الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكب الله
اكب
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرح والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومنه ومن تبع
باحسان ال يوم
الدين بعد شا
الله ضراح
سه البقره يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب عليكم
صيا كما كتب على الذين قبلكم لعلكم
تتقون
الله
علكم فمن شهد منكم
‏prescription
[Silence]
صل عليه وسلم اتق الله
حيثما
eing mindful
[Silence]
ثول الله صلق حيثما الله سبحان وتى
‏trans different
things other
things people
‏trans
[Silence]
‏every action of believer should be gued
by this
simp .
‏how
days mind
[Silence]
معلنا من المقين
اللعلق الل جعلنا من المقين ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم
وقنا شحمات وقنا شرفت المسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل مناك السمي العليم وتب علينا يا مواب
الرحيم صلى الله على محد و اله وصحبه
اجمين برحتك الرامين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللين
[Silence]
استووا
واعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف ريت
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك ن
ستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
زين للناس حب الشهوات من
النساء والبنين والقناطير
المقنطره من الذهب والفضه والخيل المسومه
والانعام
والحرث ذلك متاع الحياه الدنيا والله عنده
حسن
الماب قل
اانبي بخير من ذلكم للذين اتقوا عن عند
ربهم جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها وازواج مطهره ورضوان من
الله والله بصير
بالعباد الذين يقولون ربنا اننا امنا
فاغفر لنا ذنوبنا وقنا عذاب
النار الصابرين والصادقين
والقانتين
والمنفقين
والمستغفرين بالاسحار
شهد الله انه لا اله الا هو
والملائكه واولو العلم
قائما
بالقسط لا اله الا هو العزيز
الحكيم ان الدين عند الله الاسلام
وما اختلف الذين اوتوا الكتاب الا من بعد
ما
جاءهم العلم بغيا
بينهم ومن يكفر بايات الله فان الله سريع
الحساب فان
حاجوك فقل اسلمت وجهي لله ومن
اتبعن وقل للذين اوتوا الكتاب الاميين اا
اسلمتم فان اسلموا فقد اهتدوا وان تولوا
فانما عليك
البلاغ والله بصير
بالعباد ان الذين يكفرون بايات الله
ويقتلون
النبيين بغير حق
ويقتلون ويقتلون الذين يامرون بالقس من
الناس فبشرهم بعذاب
اليم ويقتلون الذين يامرون بالقسط من
الناس فبشرهم بعذاب اليم
اولئك الذين حبطت اعمالهم في الدنيا
والاخره وما لهم من
ناصرين الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا
من الكتاب يدعون الى كتاب الله ليحكم
بينهم ثم يتولى فريق منهم وهم
معرضون ذلك بانهم قالوا لن تمسنا النار
الا اياما
معدودات وغرهم في دينهم ما كانوا
يفترون فكيف اذا جمعناه ليوم لا ريب
فيه ووفيت كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا
يظلمون قل اللهم مالك الملك تؤتي الملك من
تشاء وتنزع الملك ممن تشاء وتعز من
تشاء وتذل من
تشاء بيدك خير انك على كل شيء
قدير تولج الليل في النهار وتولج النهار
في الليل وتخرج الحي من الميت وتخرج الميت
من
الحي وترزق من
تشاء بغير
حساب لا يتخذ المؤمنون الكافرين اولياء من
دون
المؤمنين ومن يفعل ذلك فليس من الله في
شيء الا ان تتقوا منهم
تقاه ويحذركم الله نفسه والى الله
المصير قل ان تخفوا ما في صدوركم او تبدوه
يعلمه
الله ويعلم ما في السماوات وما في الارض
والله على كل شيء
قدير يوم تجد كل نفس ما عملت من خير
محضرا وما عملت من
سوء تود لو ان بينها وبينه امدا
بعيدا ويحذركم الله نفسه والله رؤوف
بالعباد
قل ان كنتم تحبون الله فاتبعوني يحببكم
الله ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم والله غفور
رحيم قل اطيعوا الله
والرسول فان تولوا فان الله لا يحب
الكافرين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرح الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ان الله اصطفى ادم ونوحا وال ابراهيم وال
عمران على
العالمين ذريه بعضها من بعض والله سميع
عليم اذ قالت امراه عمران رب اني نذرت لك
ما في بطني محررا فتقبل مني انك انت
السميع
العليم فلما وضعتها قالت رب اني وضعتها
انثى والله اعلم بما
وضعت وليس الذكر
كالانثى واني سميتها مريم واني اعيذها بك
وذريتها من الشيطان الرجيم
فتقبلها ربها بقبول حسن وانبتها نباتا
حسنا وكفلها
زكريا كلما دخل عليها زكريا المحراب وجد
عندها رزقا قال يا مريم انا لك هذا قالت
هو من عند
الله ان الله يرزق من يشاء
بغير
حساب هنالك دعا زكريا
ربه قال رب هب لي من لدنك ذريه طيبه انك
سميع
الدعاء فنادته الملائكه وهو قائم يصلي في
المحراب ان الله يبشرك بيحيى
ان الله يبشرك بيحيى مصدقا بكلمه من الله
وسيدا وحصورا ونبيا من
الصالحين قال رب انا يكون لي غلام وقد
بلغني الكبر وامراتي عاقر قال كذلك الله
يفعل ما
يشاء قال رب اجعل لي ايه قال ايتك الا
تكلم الناس ثلاثه ايام الا رمزا واذكر ربك
كثيرا وسبح بالعشي والابكار
واذ قالت الملائكه يا مريم ان الله اصطفاك
وطهرك واصطفاك على نساء
العالمين يا مريم قنتي لربك واسجدي واركعي
مع
الراكعين ذلك من انباء الغيب نوحيه اليك
وما كنت
لديهم وما كنت لديهم اذ يلقون اقلامهم
ايهم يكفل مريم وما كنت لديهم اذ يختصمون
اذ قالت الملائكه يا مريم ان الله يبشرك
بكلمه منه اسمه المسيح عيسى ابن مريم
وجيها في الدنيا
والاخره وجيها في الدنيا والاخره ومن
المقربين ويكلم الناس في المهد وكهلا ومن
الصالحين قالت رب ان يكون لي ولد ولم
يمسسني بشر قال كذلك الله يخلق ما
يشاء اذا قضى امرا فانما يقول له كن
فيكون ويعلمه الكتاب والحكمه والتوراه
والانجيل ورسولا الى بني
اسرائيل اني قد جئتكم بايه من
ربكم اني اخلق لكم من الطين كهيئه الطير
فانفخ فيه فيكون طيرا باذن
الله وابرئ الاكمه والابرص واحيي الموتى
باذن
الله وانبئكم بما تاكلون وما تدخرون في
بيوتكم ان في ذلك لا
لكم ان كنتم
مؤمنين ومصدقا لما بين يدي من التوراه
ولاحل لكم بعض الذي حرم عليكم وجئتكم بايه
من ربكم فاتقوا الله
واطيعون ان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه
هذا صراط
مستقيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين ان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه هذا صراط
مستقيم فلما احس عيسى منهم الكفر قال من
انصاري الى الله قال الحواريون نحن انصار
الله امنا بالله واشهد بانا
مسلمون ربنا امنا بما ربنا امنا بما انزلت
واتبعنا الرسول فاكتبنا مع
الشاهدين ومكروا ومكر الله والله خير
الماكرين اذ قال الله يا عيسى اني متوفيك
ورافعك الي ومطهرك من الذي
كفروا وجاعل الذين اتبعوك فوق الذين كفروا
الى يوم
القيامه ثم الي مرجعكم فاحكم بينكم فيما
كنتم فيه
تختلفون فاما الذين كفروا فاعذهم عذابا
شديدا في الدنيا والاخره وما لهم من
ناصرين واما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
فيوفيهم
اجورهم والله لا يحب
الظالمين ذلك نتلوه عليك من الايات والذكر
الحكيم ان مثل عيسى عند الله كمثل ادم
خلقه من تراب ثم قال له كن
فيكون الحق من ربك فلا تكن من الممترين
فمن
حاجك فيه من بعد ما جاءك من الحق فقل
تعالوا ندع
ابناءنا
وابناءكم
ونساءنا
ونساءكم وانفسنا وانفسكم ثم
نبتهل فمن
جك فيه من بعد ما جاءك من العلم فقل
تعالوا ندع
ابناءنا
وابناءكم فقل تعالوا ندع
وابناءكم
ونساءنا
ونساءكم
وانفسنا
وانفسكم ثم
نبتهل ثم نبتهل فنجعل لعنه الله على
الكاذبين ان هذا لهو القصص الحق وما من
اله الا
الله وان الله لهو العزيز
الحكيم قل يا اهل الكتاب تع فان تولوا فان
الله عليم بالمفسدين قل يا اهل الكتاب
تعالوا الى كلمه
سواء بيننا وبينكم الا نعبد الا
الله الا نعبد الا الله ولا نشرك به شيئا
ولا يتخذ بعضنا بعضا اربابا من دون
الله فان تولوا فقولوا اشهدوا بانا
مسلمون يا اهل الكتاب لم تحا
جون في ابراهيم وما انزلت التوراه
والانجيل الا من بعده افلا تعقلون ها انتم
هؤلاء حاججتم فيما لكم به علم فلم
تحاجون فيما ليس لكم به علم والله يعلم
وانتم لا تعلمون
ما كان ابراهيم يهوديا ولا نصرانيا ولكن
كان حنيفا مسلما ولم يك من الم وما كان من
المشركين ان اولى الناس بابراهيم للذين
اتبعوه وهذا النبي والذين
امنوا والله ولي
المؤمنين ود الطا طائفه من اهل الكتاب لو
يضلونكم وما يضلون الا انفسهم وما
يشعرون يا اهل الكتاب لم تكفرون بايات
الله وانتم
تشهدون يا اهل الكتاب لم تلبسون الحق
بالباطل وتكتمون الحق وانتم
تعلمون وقال
طائفه من اهل الكتاب امنوا بالذي انزل على
الذين امنوا وج النهار واكفروا اخره لعلهم
يرجعون ولا تؤمنوا الا لمن تبع دينكم قل
ان الهدى هدى الله ان يؤتى احد مثل ما
اوتيتم او
يحاجوكم عن عند
ربكم قل ان الفضل بيد الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله واسع
عليم يختص برحمته من
يشاء والله ذو الفضل
العظيم الله اكبر
سميع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ومن اهل الكتاب من ان تامنه
بقنطار يؤده اليك ومنهم من ان تامنه
بدينار لا يؤده اليك الا ما دمت عليه
قائما ذلك بانهم قالوا ليس علينا في الامي
سبيل ويقولون على الله الكذب وهم
يعلمون بلى من اوفى بعهده واتقى فان الله
يحب
المتقين ان الذين يشترون بعهد الله
وايمانهم ثمنا قليلا اولئك لا خلاق لهم في
الاخره ولا يكلمهم الله ولا ينظر اليهم
يوم القيامه ولا يزكيهم ولهم عذاب
اليم وان منهم لفريقا يلوون السنتهم
بالكتاب لتحسبوه من الكتاب وما هو من
الكتاب ويقولون هو من عند الله وما هو من
عند
الله ويقولون على الله الكذب وهم
يعلمون ما كان لبشر ان يؤتيه الله الكتاب
والحكم
والنبوه ثم يقول للناس كونوا عبادا لي من
دون
الله ولكن كونوا ربانيين بما كنتم تعلمون
الكتاب وبما كنتم تدرسون
ولا يامركم ان تتخذوا الملائكه والنبيين
اربابا ايامركم بالكفر بعد اذ انتم
مسلمون واذ اخذنا ميثاق النبيين لم واذ
اخذنا ميثاق النبيين لما لما
اتيتكم واذ اخذ الله ميثاق النبي لما
اتيتكم من كتاب وحكمه ثم جاءكم رسول مصدق
لما معكم
لتؤمنن به ولتنصرنه
قال اقررتم واخذتم على ذلكم اصري قالوا
اقررنا قال فاشهدوا وانا معكم من
الشاهدين فمن تولى بعد ذلك فاولئك هم
الفاسقون افغير دين الله
يبغون وله اسلم من في السماوات والارض
طوعا وكرها واليه
يرجعون قل امنا بالله وما انزل علينا وما
انزل على ابراهيم واسماعيل واسحاق ويعقوب
والاسباط وما اوتي موسى وعيسى
والنبيون من
ربهم لا نفرق بين احد منهم ونحن له
مسلمون ومن يبتغ غير الاسلام دينا فلن
يقبل منه وهو في الاخره من
الخاسرين كيف يهدي الله قوما كفروا بعد
ايمانهم وشهدوا ان الرسول حق
وجاءهم
البينات والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين اولئك جزاؤهم ان عليهم لعنه الله
والملائكه والناس
اجمعين خالدين فيها لا يخفف عنهم العذاب
ولا هم ينظرون
الا الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك واصلحوا فان
الله غفور
رحيم ان الذين كفروا ان الذين كفروا بعد
ايمانهم ثم ازدادوا كفرا لن تقبل توبتهم
واولئك هم
الضالون ان الذين كفروا ماتوا وهم كفار
فلن يقبل من احدهم ملء الارض ذهبا ولو
افتدى به اولئك لهم عذاب اليم وما لهم من
ناصرين لن تنالوا البر حتى تنفقوا مما
تحبون وما تنفقوا من شيء
فان الله به
عليم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الشف
والوت الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون حياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي دين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الد دين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من تول ليت وبارك اللهم
لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر
ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك اللهم من كل ذنب وخطيئه
ونتوب اليك
نؤمن بك ونتوكل عليك ونكل اليك الامر
كله اللهم اغفر مننا اللهم اغفر لنا
الذنوب واستر منا العيوب وتب علينا يا
مولانا كي نتوب اللهم انت ربنا لا اله الا
انت خلقتنا ونحن عبيدك
واماك ونحن على عهدك ووعدك ما استطعنا
نعوذ بك من شرور ما صنعنا نبوء لك بنعمك
علينا ونبوء
بذنوبنا ونبوء بذنوبنا فاغفر لنا فانه لا
يغفر الذنوب الا انت ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا
ظلما كثيرا وانه لا يغفر الذنوب الا انت
فاغفر لنا مغفره من عندك وارحمنا
انك انت الغفور
الرحيم اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول
به بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا
به جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا
مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما ابقيت واجعله وارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا
تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا
تجعل الى النار مصيرنا واجعل الجنه هي
دارنا
وقرارنا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار الله
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق
رقابنا من النار برحمتك يا عزيز يا غفار
اللهم اجعلنا ممن يصوم رمضان ايمانا
واحتسابا واجعلنا ممن يقوم رمضان ايمانا
واحتسابا واغفر لنا الذنوب كلها يا رب
العالمين رب اغفر وارحم واعفو وتكرم
وتجاوز عما تعلم انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك
انت الله الاعز الاكرم انك انت الله الاعز
الاكرم سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وصل اللهم وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه والتابعين
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏ja